este 4 de agosto los ibaneses han salido
a la calle por muchas razones para
recordar a las más de 200 Víctimas de la
explosión del puerto de beirut para
exigir que haya un proceso judicial
limpio para poder llevar a la justicia y
que rindan cuentas los culpables y para
exigir mejores condiciones de vida ahora
que los libaneses cada día son más
pobres ha habido tres marchas
simultáneas en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad que han convertido aquí en la
Estatua del emigrante donde a las 6 y 7
minutos
se guardará Un minuto de silencio por
las víctimas por parte de las
autoridades no ha habido ninguna
conmemoración oficial simplemente se han
limitado a dar mensajes de apoyo a los
ciudadanos libaneses por la mayor
tragedia que han vivido en su historia y
que haya un proceso limpio de Justicia
algo que los leoneses ven como un atleta
política justamente en el momento con
los manifestantes estaban marchando aquí
hacia el puerto otro de los Silos se ha
derrumbado siendo este el quinto desde
el pasado domingo y el colapso de los
Silos es como una metáfora de la
negligencia del gobierno por no haber
protegido a sus ciudadanos y por no
haber sabido proteger el puerto de be